der Morgen danach in der kaffeebarmen
Parlament Italien hat gewählt und sich
für eine rechtes Bündnis entschieden
Georgia Meloni von den
postfaschistischen fratelli d'Italia an
der Spitze
sie ist etwas Neues ihr Wahlkampf war
nicht geprägt von Hass sondern sie hat
sich auf die sozialen Probleme
konzentriert
findet Paolo Zoan und rund 26% der
Menschen in Italien Meloni hat den
Wahlkampf genutzt um ihr radikales Image
abzumildern ihre Töne heute Nacht leise
[Applaus]
Situationen der sich Europa befindet der
wir uns stellen müssen ist sehr komplex
und wir müssen alle mithelfen das
braucht nun eine ruhige Atmosphäre und
gegenseitige Respekt das ist die Basis
für Dialog in einer demokratischen
Gesellschaft
noch wenige Wochen vor dem Wahlkampf
klingt Meloni viel schärfer
ja zur natürlichen Familie Nein zur LGBT
Community ja zu christlichen Prinzipien
Nein zu islamistischer Gewalt
ja zur sicheren Grenzen Nein zu
Masseneinwanderung ja zu unseren
Mitbürgern Nein zur internationalen
Finanzwelt ja zur Unabhängigkeit der
Völker Nein zu den Bürokraten in Brüssel
[Musik]
ist Journalist schreibt kritisch über
rechte Parteien seitdem lebt er unter
Polizeischutz
sie beschränkt sich bestenfalls darauf
zu sagen dass es den Faschismus nicht
mehr geben würde was eine Art ist nichts
zu sagen es ist das Modell der alten
rechten das aber in ein neues Gewand
gekleidet ist
sie nennen sich konservative und
Reformisten in Wirklichkeit findet man
dazwischen aber jede Menge Faschisten
Meloni soll das Land in die Zukunft
führen aber die Partei hängt in der
Vergangenheit ihr Partner Salvini von
der leger und Silvio Berlusconi mit
seiner Forza Italia haben beide stark
verloren die Frau an der Spitze das wäre
das erste Mal für Italien
frei schreibt die rechtskonservative
Libero wie viele sich wirklich freuen
unklar die Wahlbeteiligung war noch nie
so niedrig die Zukunft wie immer
ungewiss selten hält eine Regierung hier
länger als anderthalb Jahre
ich hoffe dass Europa Italien hören wird
aber ich weiß es nicht
so hoffen die einen dass Italien unter
Meloni weiter Hilfe von Europa bekommt
die anderen hoffen auf Italien zuerst
und wir fragen nach bei unserem
Korrespondenten in Rom Andreas Postel
schönen guten Tag nach Rom also das
rechte Bündnis insgesamt hat klar
gewonnen dazu lag die Wahlbeteiligung
historisch niedrig bei 64 Prozent was
heißt dieses ganze Wahlergebnis jetzt
für Italien
ja also an dieser historisch niedrigen
Wahlbeteiligung lässt sich schon absehen
diese Politikverdrossenheit die da zum
Ausdruck kommt die italienischen Wähler
haben teilweise gar nicht gewusst wen
sie wem sie ihre Stimme geben sollen und
die einzige Oppositionspartei die sich
in der vergangenen Legislaturperiode
hier angeboten hat für die Wähler in
Italien das war die fratellit Italia das
hat Georgia Meloni schon ganz geschickt
gemacht sich rauszuhalten aus dem
Regierungshandeln und sich anzubieten
als Sammelbecken für alle die
enttäuschten frustrierten und
unzufriedenen und das hat offensichtlich
den Ausschlag gegeben für dieses er
Wahlergebnis gleichzeitig muss jetzt
Georgia miloni selbstverständlich ihre
postfaschistischen Kernklientel Zucker
geben das ist ganz bestimmt zu erwarten
in Italien und auf der anderen Seite hat
sie Signale nach Europa gesetzt alles
wird nicht so schlimm man steht zu
Europa man steht so transatlantischen
Bündnissen man steht auch zu
Waffenlieferungen an die Ukraine also
das wird sich zeigen wie dann letzten
Endes italienische Politik sich unter
ihr ausgestalten wird wenn sie dann
Ministerpräsidentin hier in Italien
werden sollte Einschätzung von unserem
Korrespondenten in Rom Andreas Postel
vielen Dank und das Stichwort Europa das
ist eben schon gefallen deswegen
sprechen wir jetzt mit dem
luxemburgischen außenminister Jean
asselborner ist der dienstälteste in der
EU und schon sehr sehr lange dabei
schönen guten Tag Jean Asselborn nach
Luxemburg
guten Tag meiner also wir sehen jetzt
das Ergebnis in Italien auch in Schweden
hat es ja ein rechtes Lager gegeben was
gewonnen hat bei der Wahl in Ungarn gibt
es bereits eine rechte Regierung bewegt
sich ganz Europa nach rechts
ich hoffe nicht allerdings dass hier die
rechte gewonnen hat dass hat man ja
gesehen an den ersten Gratulanten AFD
lebende Nationalisten aus Spanien
wir müssen jetzt schauen dass wir einen
Schritt nach dem anderen machen also ich
bin natürlich auch etwas skeptisch wir
haben hier mit einer Partei zu tun
fratelli d'Italia die noch immer die
Flamme in Ihrem Logo hat und diese
Flamme kommt ja aus düsteren Zeiten sie
sagt zwar die
Meloni dass man dass sie nichts mehr zu
tun haben mit Faschismus
basierend auf salini ich hoffe das so
ich hatte auch gesagt dass sie in der
Europäischen Union mithelfen will
ich glaube das ist auch für Italien das
allerbeste der Gegenteil wäre glaube ich
schädlich für Italien wissen sie in
diesem Moment denn ist das sehr gut dass
wir die Europäische Union haben und die
Verträge der Europäischen Union haben
das ist keine Garantie das nichts
passiert wir wissen das ja aber trotzdem
ist er sein Gerüst dass die Werte der
Europäischen Union zusammenhält und auch
Italien werden wird in Zukunft es nicht
fertig bringen über die Werte über diese
Werte zu springen aber fangen wir hier
ab was in der Substanz von dieser
Regierung
entschieden wird wissen sie nichts ist
wertvoller vor allem heute aus dieser
rechtsstaatsmechanismus das heißt wenn
man Geld aus der Europäischen Union
haben will muss man auch als Europäer
Politik machen das heißt die Demokratie
respektieren die Werte respektieren die
Solidarität auch respektieren und es
kommt hier vor allem auf die Kommission
an dieser Interpretation des
rechtsstaatsmechanismus das hier nichts
aufgeweicht wird und das wird auch
Madame Meloni und die die dann die
Regierung bilden sehr schnell wissen und
das ist für mich die größte Garantie
dass Italien ein Land bleibt was in
Zukunft sich das dritte Land das
drittgrößte Land im Euro in der
Eurogruppe was die Richtung
der europäischen sagen wir mal der
europäischen Werte trotzdem respektiert
dann schauen wir noch mal drauf also wir
haben von unserem Korrespondenten eben
gehört dass es vor allem eine große
Politikverdrossenheit gab in Italien
manche vielleicht auch gar nicht wussten
wenn sie da gewählt haben wie erklären
sie sich denn den Erfolg der rechten
Parteien
ja also muss aufpassen ob sie nicht
wissen wenn Sie gewählt haben diese
Kampagne war kurz aber trotzdem ganz
klar Draghi wurde in Europa wirklich als
einer dargestellt und das wissen ja auch
die meisten Italiener er hat sie durch
auch diese covid-krise geführt mit
konnte vorher zusammen das waren
europäisch Angestellte Premierministers
warum ist dieser Umschwung gekommen sind
viele Italiener die wollen vielleicht
etwas Neues sehen andere an anderen Kopf
sehen an der Spitze aber es genügt nicht
etwas Neues zu haben man muss wissen und
ich hoffe dass die Italiener das Wissen
dass Europa solange es besteht in der
Form wie es in den Verträgen
festgehalten ist sich Wert gegen
Nationalismus ich dieses
Amerika zuerst oder Italien zuerst das
sind Sachen die vor allem in der
Europäischen Union nicht Schule machen
dürfen wir sind eine
gesundheitsgemeinschaft eines
Solidargemeinschaft in der Europäischen
Union und auch Italien muss dazu stehen
wir sind eine ja genau
sie haben es schon angesprochen wir sind
eine Solidargemeinschaft wir haben
gemeinsam beispielsweise auch Sanktionen
gegen Russland beschlossen wie sehen Sie
das jetzt mit den neuen Bündnissen hält
diese gemeinsame Allianz noch
also sogar
Ungarn und Orban die reden zwar viel
gegen die Sanktionen sind aber bis jetzt
immer solidarisch gewesen weil ich
glaube sie ist sie es sich nicht trauen
hier auszusehren und so wäre das auch
mit Italien sein es gab ja auch Stimmen
in dieser Bündnis jetzt dieses Rechte
Bündnis die ganz klar gesagt haben dass
sie zu den Sanktionen stehen ich glaube
hier ist jedenfalls nicht direkt die
Gefahr die Gefahr ist eine latente
Gefahr dass so eine eine ja ein Diktator
heute ein Krimineller Kriegstreiber wie
wie Putin es ist dass er Anhänger haben
könnte noch geistige Anhänger haben
könnte in dieser in diesem Bündnis in
Italien und das glaube ich das muss sehr
schnell verschwinden die Europäische
Union glaube ich ist stark genug um
Italienisch den Italienern auch in der
Regierung freundschaftlich zu sagen dass
wir hier eine Linie haben die Linien
sind Sanktionen die Linien Hilfen für
die Ukraine und die Linie ist dass wir
unsere Gesellschaft in Europa nicht auf
dem Weg bringen wollen wie Putin das
getan hat mit Russland und das geht nur
wenn wir die Werte die Demokratie
hochhalten live aus Luxemburg der
luxemburgische außenminister Jean
Asselborn vielen Dank für Ihre Zeit
heute
bitte sehr